how do you figure out when you're not  the person for the task you're doing and  you should hire somebody  if you're truly obsessed with  accomplishing your goal it becomes  very easy to see i'm really trying to  build the next disney i want to  play my role in building that thing then  you are going to  desperately look for the people that can  do the things that you can't do  the very thing that gives me self-esteem  is going i don't know this but they do  and then to celebrate them and say  they came up with this idea because  selfishly that's how you get more good  ideas because when people know that  you're not going to steal it from them  you're going to celebrate them then you  can actually make progress